[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there are different ways to make films
that have CG characters what we're
interested in with performance capture
is the totality of the Performance
Physical emotional facial the eyes
everything the actor creates the emotion
the actor creates the moment it's our
job to make sure that everything the
actor did is preserved in their CG
character you are very hard on them
thank you
I'm the father it's my job everything
that Jake Sully as a navi does Sam has
done
I thought we lost them
[Music]
you can capture the emotion you can
capture the subtleties the nuances of
the movements you can capture the eye
and capture the ticks everything capture
it all I'll be nice once
then I won't
the moment I saw her for the first time
I was just like you're just so beautiful
blue has never looked more beautiful
the amazing thing is that the technology
gives me that portal to bring my 14 year
old self to play this girl avatars only
go around
in making a movie set on Pandora
doesn't exist avatars don't exist at
nine foot tall we have actors working in
a volume with markers on their body
facial head rigs on their head and we
capture a hundred percent of their
performance in the digital world at the
beginning of the day the first thing we
do is get into the performance capture
suit and that is a skin tight two-piece
and it's totally filled with ping
pong-like pools around us so they can
then track my arm and then translate
that into the virtual world they have
all these little cameras that send these
little rays which give an image of you
moving around so every little movement
is your movement and then we put a head
rig on and it's a helmet and it has a
camera that's right in front of your
face one of the big advances that we've
made technologically on the sequels is
the facial performance capture we're
capturing a much higher Fidelity of
performance I know one thing
[Music]
this family is our Fortress
[Music]
I've done a lot of green screen I've
done a lot of blue screen but never
anything of course like this where there
really is no screen you're just acting
in a space no you must stand
cells I've always thought that being in
the volume is about playing and
Imagination and there is no kind of fear
or no shame you can do whatever you need
to do to get to that truth saving their
lives that's all that matters I have had
to work completely differently than I
ever have before and it's been an
amazing experience to go back in time
why am I different
[Music]
it is just remarkable to be able to see
the movements and the performance go
straight into the character and it's
like there's Kate and hey there's
Renault so that has been fascinating to
me
what is this done away
no what is this
I find as a director I'm much more
attuned to the actors because that's all
I have to worry about I'm not distracted
by the camera move or the extras in the
background I'm just there for them
that's all I care about that's all I'm
watching it's an amazing process it's
also the only way to do it it's the only
way to make this film
why do you come to us
I just want to keep my family safe
[Music]
treat them as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
far sport
if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
Outcast that's all they see
I see
[Music]
my warrior like you I'm supposed to
fight
protect the people
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get it done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]
it's on sale now
[Music]